so what's going on with you and chloe i
mean you know
some days are good and some days you
know she gets a little frustrated about
you know what's going on with the media
i don't even think it's to her anymore
about like getting over the past like
things that you guys have been through i
think it's just mostly what other people
are going to think
yeah i don't even i think she's totally
fine otherwise she won't be hanging out
with you 24
7. that's tristan thompson asking his
girlfriend khloe kardashian's sister kim
for advice you know what i'm saying so
that's like my mentality and
and she's gotta understand it too it's a
sneak peek from the final season of
keeping up with the kardashians
and chloe well she had some choice words
in response to a comment someone left
about the clip on social media
let's start with tristan and kim hi
what's up
do you always have to duck when you go
through a doorway it depends
in the clip the 40 year old reality star
offers these words of wisdom
i mean honestly i just think that you
should talk to her
i think you should just tell her like
you don't want to rush her process
but if you were to just like explain to
her that you don't want to be
this like kept secret because she is so
embarrassed
like that makes you sad and that makes
you
you know feel away yeah kim adds she's
surprised by chloe's reaction to the
ongoing spotlight on her relationship
with tristan
i'm carrying a suitcase of like other
people's opinions and thoughts
and i just never thought she was like
that i just feel like it's
so that wasn't who she was
like you're never gonna get to the
finish line if you're trying to always
please the masses so like you just gotta
just live for yourself
then on thursday this side of chloe
spilled out across social media
she's always like the tough chloe that
doesn't give up
a kardashian fan account on instagram
posted kim and tristan's chat
and someone commented so is kylie
allowed to be friends with jordan again
this prompted an immediate clap back by
chloe who wrote this lengthy comment in
response
quote i'm so sick and tired of this
narrative that i control my sister or i
dictate who she chooses to surround
herself with
never once have i ever and i mean ever
told my sister who she can be friends
with
she is an adult who can do whatever she
wants to do
chloe added by the way i have no ill
feelings towards
anyone truly my heart carries no hatred
at all
unless you actually know what you're
talking about respectfully
shut the [ __ ] up it will keep me posted
no i will
i will you know i will chloe and tristan
rekindled their
romance last year following his cheating
scandal with kylie's former bff
jordan woods you know things happen and
of course i'm sorry and apologetic as
much as i can be
the scandal's aftermath could be seen in
moments like these on
keeping up with the kardashians the
glass
come on you see how it looks
look at the smoker everyone cheat off on
the test thank god you said on a test
in january e.t learned that following
tristan joining the boston celtics last
year
chloe has been splitting her time
between the coasts with a source telling
us quote
they're doing well as a couple and
continuing to focus on raising true
together and be the best parents that
they can be as
always it's a beautiful thing
and chloe has been sharing the lighter
moments of their long-distance
relationship
she recently posted this cute video of
daughter true seeing tristan on tv
during an nba game
oh it's a commercial now he'll come back
the proud dad later posted the video to
his instagram
and wrote love my tutu